you can probably be way more than double
on yours
yeah the nicholas canyon nickels cane
that was beautiful
it was rad did you ever have water going
through the creek there oh yeah most of
the time it would go through until like
this like multi-year drought happened
yeah but yeah it like it at least
tripled like who were your famous
neighbors there didn't you have helped
down the street and yeah the crazy thing
was it wasn't
like um you know steve um i don't know
did you have a beef with henry henry i
didn't have a beef with him but we had
this woman
this year this young lass
uh who
i mean there's no polite way to say it
she had been passed around the jackass
cast and uh
and uh pontius and i even shared her
at one time you know
at the same time at the same time
was that the vagina contest it was a new
year's day it was january 1st of 2002
okay like the jackass offices were just
opening but we had not started filming
jackass
the first movie yet
and uh
new year's day we had done like every
drug in the book the night before
mushrooms and and coke and ecstasy like
like cocaine
i mean dude it was
ridiculous it was ridiculous this was a
party with like the whole cast like
there was a party but we ended up back
in my apartment with this young lass for
your own party yeah for our own party
and the sun was up
right there it was the i had to pull out
sofa we were on the pull-out sofa in the
living room wow and this remarkable
occurrence happened
where
we both emitted
and it like if we weren't so many drugs
we weren't so many drugs it was like it
happened in slow motion
i saw our semen flying through the air
both of our siemens and atlanta it
landed on this this woman at the exact
same time
coming from like different
like like coming
and that was when she said i wish i had
two mouths because that was because that
would have saved her from turning her
head back and forth
oh my gosh yeah but uh but but this this
woman in particular
that this this this um this lady i speak
of yes
had identified henry rollins as uh a
love interest
apparently like uh is she in town
visiting
apparently like she would make trips to
spend time with with him okay and uh
and and so i just thought that was like
so so fascinating and and i would try to
press her for
for information we're both huge bronze
yeah
flag fans we love rollins you're saying
this night you tried to or like you
would see her over that's why she was in
town in general yeah i think it might
have been why she's in town to visit him
but i don't know i can't say for sure
but i was like i remember pressing her
for information i was like so when
you're making love with him and rollins
he groans right
i know he does come on
tommy he grumps
i mean i can't even confirm that they
even had a relationship but i just like
the idea is cool the idea went like my i
went crazy with it okay and uh and i
went on the howard stern show with that
young lady
okay and she was doing all kinds of
crazy stuff i remember literally took
her shirt off didn't she yeah
immediately took her shirt off and she
was rolling like she rolled a pool ball
out of her boobs like onto a light bulb
on my head breaking the light bulb like
really high level stuff
yeah
and uh and i told howard stern all about
my ideas of what i thought her
relationship with mr rollins might have
been like wow so i just assumed that mr
rollins was none too pleased with me
but later he said he never even heard
about any of it
which do you believe that i don't
believe it
yeah
well to complete the story for people
because i've heard you tell this story
before
when you when they did the tattoo the
offerings had two on youtube they told
me it was gonna be nicki six driving
this hummer and i was like snorting
cocaine off a picture of me and nikki
sixx
like uh waiting for my hero nikki six to
show up like as if he was gonna be
really impressed that i was starting
cocaine off a picture of him because
he's sober right i think he was so bad
at that time
you were doing this at the job site
waiting
i was doing it
i was like a little boy just so excited
to meet us
i was out in the open doing cocaine for
the entire [ __ ] first movie the only
scenes that i was not on cocaine for
that whole first movie were the ones we
filmed in japan because i couldn't find
cocaine in japan
so yeah i'm just starting storing a coke
and they end up and they say okay dude
this suv pulls up they say okay stevo
your [ __ ] hero nikki six has arrived
go up and [ __ ] and go greet him do
they know he wasn't him they're just
yeah
i go i go i go up to the suv and [ __ ]
henry rollins gets out and i thought oh
my god this is a big thing he's going to
kick my ass because he hates me
but he was nice as could be yeah he's
super nice he was it was awkward though
he was sober too
he's always been sober right there
well wait chris you guys knew so was the
prank just like oh it's not nikki sixth
or whatever we all expect oh god he's
gonna be so freaked out we have another
one
yeah we're so excited yeah because
you're there for that yeah
oh yeah did you think henry ross was
going to beat him up or was that your
hope
it'll be funny i didn't know i don't
know what was gonna i didn't know i
didn't want him to get beaten up sure if
if if he did like if something really
happened if it went too far chris would
have i would
[Laughter]
but it was just awkward kind of but then
henry was rad but then you know what i
did henry rollins was the [ __ ]
coolest you know what i did though like
the second night i actually like the day
after i moved into my house i had some
friends over some some girls that i was
friends with and i was like henry
rowlands lives down the street and
they're like oh my god i want to go
serenade him and this was like after
we're home from the bar like like super
late at night and so we walked down the
street with one of them's got an
acoustic guitar and she starts singing
um every rose has a storm like to his
front door like so loud and i just moved
in
and like and then like you know like we
run off you know laughing and then like
the next night i'm just walking down the
hill like and he happens to be like out
front cleaning his garage and so i run
into him stupidly i introduced myself
from jackass and he's like any i he had
to have known it was me
and i and he's like are you a pa i'm
like no i'm one of the jackets yeah
jackass guys and i moved up the street
and um it was pretty obvious that it was
i was probably like involved in that
serenade but he didn't mention it
and then um and then years later like
rollins had a knoxville on his show
oh yeah what show uh i think it was
called the henry rollins show it was on
in a podcast
no it was on oh it's like a tv sxm it
was on a channel some i can't remember
what it was it wasn't a very good talk
show though to be honest with you
because it seemed like maybe
he might have talked too much
ah there's no shows like that yeah yeah
so it sounds like a podcast but but
knoxville brought up that i lived up the
street from him and he's like oh yeah i
was serenaded once or something like
that and that's all he said
but uh
so he pretends to not know he's probably
never
i
you know
i don't know 15 years he probably lived
by me here but he moved before i did one
time someone a bum set a fire across the
street from his house accidentally like
their camp was caught on fire and
everyone like ran down to watch the fire
and he was there but he didn't talk to
me like he was pretty he was really to
himself every once in a while you'd see
a young lady like like that you could
tell he was briefly dating like like in
front of his house
other than that like it didn't seem like
he had company over very often
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
uh